[Musique]
arem l'été les troupes en formation de
défense que tous les hommes et se place
immédiatement sur la ligne de front dans
l'est s'est aucun en réserve
à vos ordres monsieur
[Musique]
en position resserrer les rangs monsieur
l'ennemi est trop loin on va attendre
qu'il se rapprochait
souhaitez moi bonne chance alors bonne
chance à tous les deux et on attendait
mon signal pour tirer
allez armand joue près
attendez
[Musique]
on dirait
tron
[Musique]
oh
mcafee
mission alors laissez kaput possible
d'accord
gr
[Musique]
pendant de munitions
on va être à court de munitions moi j'en
ai plus
le capitaine est touché
faute des cages et là on va le porter
jusqu'aux allées aide moi
au bar le vrai
[Musique]
on
alors visent le bien être en compte le
vent en regardant de quel côté les
feuilles se penche en et repérer
non c'est bon s'il reste c'est qu'il
nous a pas encore eu à prendre à cacher
ton souffle dans l'air
n'oublie pas
à chaque fois que tu auras ta cible
l'animal souffre un peu plus ne leur est
pas d'accord tu prêt
oui série
alors je vais fils que je cache souffle
dans l'air
je ne rate pas à qui souffre pas qu'ils
souffrent
[Musique]
le visage et le message est là
saïed fils d'hussein suisse au
grand-père une lettre de votre petit
fils soit louis merci ramazan fils d'ali
je suis sa mère
voici la lettre j'aime cet auteur osman
fils de sam je suis sam sa lettre j'ai
hâte de le revoir
je suis sûr qu'il est encore vide de
sens il va bien chrismaëlle villa mois
ci les soldats morts pour notre patrie
moussa fils d'ali
[Musique]
et dire fils de moustafa mais tin fils
de jah main
[Musique]
osman fils de savane
qua non vous m'avez donné sa lettre
[Musique]
je viens à peine de la voir
il peut donc pas être va pas passer la
semaine
isa fils d'ali espèces
gaia internet
[Musique]
tu diras moment que j'ai tué le cerfa
bras tu veux que je les monte alors mais
sinon je suis sûr qu'il va se moquer de
moi encore une fois et il va dire que je
sais pas tenir un fusil décès lui non
plus à cause de lui une fois on a dû
chasser un serpent dans trois jours il
était plus vieux que toi c'est vrai et
il c'est vrai mais notre manque pas de
lui c'est bien compris sinon je
raccroche au mur par les oreilles parce
que c'est ton ennemi
[Musique]
muttart tenue affichée l'ordre de
mobilisation au mur
[Musique]
à partir de quel âge les hommes doivent
partir dix mois ou ceux qui sont majeurs
doivent partir à la guerre
ça c'était de la bonne viande et garçons
c'était un gros cerfs il paraissait
encore plus gros quand il était vivant
allez mon grand rudin au comment tu fais
pour le tuer tu veux on t'écoute
alors au début j'ai levé mon fusil comme
ça mais après j'ai cherché la direction
du vent et là j'ai appuyé sur la
gâchette pour les tuer mais c'était pas
facile et je réussis pas vrai papa à lui
atys mange donc un autre morceau j'ai
déjà trop manger j'en peux plus je vous
ai sursis mais s'ils mangent surtout que
tu manges pour deux maintenant donc il
faut se nourrir
sinon tu vas nous faire un bébé tout
maigre non je suis sûr qu'il sera en
bonne santé et je pense que ce serait
une petite fille quand titi hassan
[Musique]
je dois partir au fond
les hommes sont mobilisés on doit tous
aller à la guerre dès demain matin aux
dardanelles
[Musique]
les mange ali
muhsin
qu'est-ce qui a
je repense à la chasse le jour où papa
nous il y avait envoyé
[Musique]
je devais tuer se sert du drame elle
j'ai jamais eu la force
j'ai jamais vu tu as toujours cru que je
l'avais raté
c'était volontaire
j'ai peur qu'au combat
oublie ça allez bonne nuit
[Musique]
mon amour dont je me languis chaque jour
si je laisse mon frère partir seul pour
affronter la mort
jamais plus je ne connaîtrai la paix
ben mon frère ne fermera pas les yeux
avant moi si je dois devenir un martyr
alors nous serons entendus
tu as fini de dire au revoir alors nous
allons pouvoir partir maman tu tues
priera pour moi tous les jours
papa
pop
tu viens d'arriver pourquoi tu repars
déjà ça ne va pas de pleurer ne pleure
pas tué mon fils et en l'absence du
domaine là c'est du courant
c'est toi l'homme de la maison
maintenant
jusqu'à notre retour du devra être fort
si l'ennemi arrive à la maison tu devra
tout faire pour défendre notre voyez ne
recule devant rien pour protéger la
famille c'est promis protège ta
grand-mère et attends tu ne l'ès pas
l'ennemi arriver jusqu'à chez nous est
entré dans notre maison coûte deux côtés
d'accord où il est d'accord a dit aussi
[Musique]
non c it fils de ramazan waret pisterait
chalon
avancez
hassan fils d'un maître
ces bons avancé
aussi de vis d'un mètre
ce n'est pas inscrit sur la liste
pourquoi êtes vous là c'est inutile
j'aime porte volonté 1
j'ai été blessé dans les balkans mais la
blessure a disparu et je suis aussi le
grand frère d'assad
laissez moi partir pour que je me batte
avec lui s'il vous plaît avancé
mostafa fils tu cèdes cher et crème mon
ami chaque jour il fait plus chaud que
la veille
les conditions de vie sur le front au
pire un peu plus chaque jour
l'armée ennemie contre laquelle nous
faisons tout pour résister a établi un
camp militaire entièrement équipée des
ennemis ne manque ni de munitions ni de
nourriture
nous pensions devoir affronter les
anglais se ses plages mais il semblerait
que des soldats d'autres nations les ai
rejoints
de nombreux pays ont allié leurs forces
nous attaquer nous nous battons pas
contre une armée anglaise mais contre
une véritable croisade de milliers de
soldats venus du monde entier
cependant ce que ces envahisseurs ignore
c'est que l'amour de notre pays est
profondément enraciné dans le coeur de
nos soldats
chacun de nos hommes est prêt à se
sacrifier pour le tri nations
jamais nous ne laisserons des étrangers
nous voler ne serait ce qu'une partie de
nos terres pour y arriver nos ennemis
devrait tuer jusqu'au dernier d'entre
nous
malgré les conditions difficiles dans
lesquelles nous combattons et leurs
ressources sont limitées
je suis certain que nous triompherons 2
ec raismes tu sais comme moi que j'ai
raison de l'affirmer tu sais également
combien j'aurais aimé défendre le pays
et partager la joie de cette future
victoire avec toi
malheureusement le destin en a décidé
autrement reçoit toute mon affection
toi qui a perdu la vie en défendant
notre pays
ton ami le capitaine ibrahima dia
[Musique]
on marche depuis cinq jours je suis
épuisé j'ai plus la force de faire un
seul pas moi accroche toi on est bientôt
arrivé aux deux vrilles être dès ce soir
quand vous serez sur le front ou vous
prierai pour pouvoir marcher vous verrez
je peux prendre de l'eau allez-y bien
sûr
monsieur le motel
[Musique]
non
ou est ce que vous étiez dans les
balkans la frontière macédonienne
moi j'étais en bulgarie en ce temps là
c'était vraiment l'enfer là-bas croyez
moi alors vous allez avoir une fille
c'est ça si tout se passe bien
oui je vous le souhaite moi j'ai trois
filles chez moi trois enfants trois
filles j'espère les revoir elle me
manque
wall street oui c'est gentil merci
la dernière est née quand j'étais dans
les balkans pendant la guerre ma fille
avait déjà bien grandi
on se l'est vu c'était déjà plus un bébé
maintenant elle doit se marier et je
suis là et vous savez je suis d'origine
albanaise et nous on ne donne pas
d'office si lent on approche de la ligne
de front et les infirmières dont me
suivre
j'arrive
merci beaucoup je serais morte sans
votre aide
non je n'ai pas fait grand chose ne me
remercie pas c'était normal de vous
aider
faites attention
merci
[Musique]
alors on devra tout faire ici et oui
allez y allez
osim en effet capitelles on ne vous
avait pas démobilisé pendant les balkans
l'armée vous a trop manqué dites moi je
tenais à défendre mon pays
eh bien j'ai apprécié cette initiative
merci capitaine
bienvenue au sergent
conduisez ces hommes là où ils pourront
se reposer à vos ordres capitaine
suivez-moi
il a combattu pour vos dans les balkans
en effet
mme aussi mais très doué
c'est un excellent soldats
qui d'entre vous a de l'expérience en
chirurgie moi j'ai déjà assisté
plusieurs chirurgiens j'administre est
de la morphine et jeu pratiqué des
opérations mineurs je vois alors venu
avec moi s'il vous plaît
tu as de manger on dirait ouais j'ai
jamais eu aussi faim réveillez vous
sortez votre gamme el celler servez les
avants nous nous on n'a pas marché merci
merci
vous venez d'où 2 mai carla dans les
montagnes je m'appelle muhsin lui c'est
mon frère hassen moi c'est loupé
je m'appelle costas moi je m'appelle une
vers berne surnomme le grand zèle banner
et fier de l'être
vous êtes ici depuis longtemps vous
depuis mon enfance
comment çà et là et les de la région il
vient du coca d'air quand j'ai su que
l'ennemi arriver jusqu'ici
j'ai pris un sac et je suis venu s'il
arrive à passer la plage ils arriveront
jusque dans nos champs s'il est ici
c'est juste pour protéger nos récoltes
on peut pas se passer d'un tel seuil
[Musique]
au niveau vip soldats étaient en
position
[Musique]
direct
ici le capitaine zafour très libre il y
est un d'artillerie servette
yat-il les tranchées sont bombardés par
une vie
on a beaucoup de blessés vous devez
faire quatre couleurs cannes en sont
trop loin ils sont hors de notre portée
on manque de munitions d'accord bien au
dessus
baïonnette au canon
[Musique]
elle
chargé
[Applaudissements]
envoyez des renforts on se motive en
deuxième ligue ne se retirent tous un
dossier
[Musique]
c'est tout ce thème
d'accord
[Musique]
ce qu'ils attaquent comme ça tous les
soirs
non pas tous les soirs mais avec eux on
ne sait jamais à quoi s'attendre donc on
reste sur nos gardes
[Musique]
aide-moi bonne portée
je lai
et côté yeux oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya
promets moi une chose que
jamais je me rends combat n'est ce pas
mon corps à l'ennemi même si on n'a pas
la même religion
je suis pas musulman mais je mérite pas
de rester sur le champ de bataille c'est
compris je te le promets costas je te
laisserai pas là bas
bien pour la pas fini
[Musique]
on les voit pourtant bien faut être
idiot pour arriver à marcher dessus
quand même les ciseaux vous savez par
les allemands c'est ma langue maternelle
donc ce serait plus simple pour moi je
parle anglais et allemand couramment
depuis des années monsieur vous avez dû
aller longtemps à l'école alors ça me
surprend de trouver des infirmières si
intelligente sur le front de netteté ça
me surprend de voir autant d'officiers
allemands sur nos terres et si vous
aviez choisi de rester à berlin on ne
serait pas sur le front et la guerre
n'aurait pas eu lieu
et vous seriez tranquillement assis à la
terrasse d'un café qu'ils emportent ça
dans la deuxième tranche et à vos ordres
capitaine bonjour soldats bonjour nous
jure qu'elle obtienne vous mourrez seul
dans la soif la faim et la douleur c'est
très bien fait en le plus possible à vos
arguments capitaine continue soldats
tout de suite monsieur ils sont très
forts en anglais malgré leur jeune âge
vous trouvez pas ismet c'est parce
qu'ils sont étudiants au maccabi sultani
on avait recruté quinze étudiants
volontaires là bas il ne reste que ces
deux-là réparer tout ce qui a été
détruit par le bombardement rice m il
faut vite réagir
d'accord
quand vous dites mais il se met semaine
ouvrez les yeux allait il se met ouvrait
les yeux il se met très vite un médecin
trouvez moi un médecin ismet ismet amics
attention
[Musique]
un homme en dieu rend justice qui
demande tire sur l'ennemi
barroso noah
et
esm et aura bien servi son pays
que son âme aille au paradis j'aimais
beaucoup il se met vous savez il est
mort dans mes bras
vous vous trompez adil nous mourrons
dans les bras de notre pays
c'est un martyr notaire mouillé de son
sang et du sang de centaines d'autres
soldats ne tomberont pas aux mains de
l'envahisseur même si cela doit nous
coûter la vie
ce n'est pas un souhait mais 1 hors
capitaine wikia tellement c'est monsieur
le style pur et demi est tout près été
tranchée plus tôt il y était j'ai
récupéré leurs armes elle pourrait nous
servir ça je ne l'oublierai pas allez
donc vous reposer un peu à vos ordres
mon capitaine
[Musique]
c'est bon les gars
vous m'avez fait appeler capitaine oui
mais aussi dans des faits oui
[Musique]
ceci est un fusil très puissant un mot
si mme may quand c'est une arme à très
longue portée à présent il est à vous
j'en ferais bon usage à compter
d'aujourd'hui vous passerez vous journée
à chasser
vous chasserons était officier de haut
rang avec ce fusil mais sachez une chose
vous n'avez pas le droit à l'erreur
puisque soyez tranquilles je ne
manquerai pas capite
vous m'avez appelé capitaine willie
giresse je voudrais te présenter muhsin
nous avons combattu ensemble dans les
balkans à partir de maintenant vous
allez former un binôme tous les deux à
vos ordres du capitaine soyez discret
rapide à chaque tir que l'ennemi n'ait
pas le temps de savoir ce qui s'est
passé ce drame était taclé m je compte
sur vous monsieur au courage
mon capitaine j'aimerais vous demander
une faveur
je vous écoute mon frère hassan il n'est
pas doué pour se battre vous savez
peut-être que vous pourriez l'envoyer
ailleurs qu'au combat ailleurs que dans
les tranchées bien
[Musique]
à la rue justice et moi qui nous tire
à l'automne mois
la qualité
trouvez ce style peuvent aller les
chapeaux
là
on est nuls au combat c'est pour ça
qu'on est là on fait pas la guerre on
porte des caisses ouais mais tu sais il
n'y a pas de rôle insignifiant pendant
une guerre et puis il faut bien que
quelqu'un se charge d'envoyer les
munitions sans nous les soldats sur le
front pourrait pas se battre vous savez
où je peux trouver à sam c'est moi
pourquoi vous avez reçu une lettre
merci yacoub tu sais lire ou pas non moi
non plus c'est pas vrai est ce que tu
sais lire non désolé tant pis je vais la
lire pour vous je veux pas vous déranger
non pas du tout merci
[Musique]
vous avez eu un petit garçon il est né
il ya trois jours il se porte très bien
jusque là elle vous attend pour choisir
le nom des petits et c'est gentil de
l'amour lui pour moi merci
j'ai un fils j'ai apprécié recoupent
je suis content pour toi c'est
formidable que j'en reviens pas
j'ai un fils j'ai un fils âgé jamais été
aussi heureux mon ami
les turcs sont arrivés devant nous
tranché et en 5 secondes
ils ont tué cinq personnes parmi eux se
trouvait même un colonel pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas réagi à quoi servait
foot ou dans cette armée à rien vous
allez donc à limiter côté le meilleur
sniper de ce fonds et me l'amener ici
sur le sang
bonsoir sergent enver bonsoir hassan ça
va tout va bien dit moi oui mais je
n'arrive pas à trouver mon frère vous
l'avez vu par hasard il est peut-être en
mission si c'est ça il ne reviendra pas
ce soir hassan vous pouvez me parler
vous savez je viens d'avoir un fils
serge année là toutes mes félicitations
j'espère qu'il se porte bien oui merci
très bien alors je vous en prie alors
allez elle a plus tard
allez tu comptes les ennemis que tu as
tué je compte mes péchés mais ce n'est
pas un péché de tuer pour sauver notre
nation
pas le péché de tuer un ennemi celui de
l'arracher à toute sa famille mais tu
sais il vaut mieux penser à ta famille à
toi mais je sais je pense que toute la
journée
je ne pense à rien d'autre ma mère mon
fils ma belle-soeur surtout hassan mon
petit frère parce que je suis tout le
temps très inquiet j'ai peur qu'il meure
au combat ton frère est sur le point
près c'est un réserviste le mien aussi
à la maison c'est mon petit frère mais
ici c'est mon capitaine
bilal
vous voyez le soldat de gauche c'est
bien lui qui m'a sauvé près de la
fontaine puis celui
[Musique]
est ce que vous le connaissez pas il
s'appelle muhsin c'est un sniper
on raconte que les ennemis tremble rien
qu'en entendant son nom n'a encore
jamais manqué une cible c'est l'un des
meilleurs snipers de l'armée
à ce qu'il paraît
il est touché tout bon
[Musique]
tout le monde peut survivre à
l'artillerie on se planque et c'est bon
mais leurs snipers là j'ai pas envie de
le croiser l'autre coup il a nettoyé
tout une tranchée personne n'a su d'où
il tirait il a déjà tué tous car
personne n'est à l'abri avec lui
bienvenue caporal eagle allons-y
je vous ferai visiter tout le camp plus
tard ma parole vous vous êtes construire
un vrai petit londres les gars oui si on
veut
le major stewart nous attend il fera
moins le grand bourgeois dans les
tranchées ouais d'être qu'on lui a dit
comme à nous qu'ils pourraient se
saouler sur la plage est gaucher avec
des orientales de canicule monsieur le
sniper que vous aviez demandé est arrivé
tu es para le william eagle monsieur
vous n'aurez pas à vous en faire leurs
snipers ne vis que les officiers donc il
n'aura pas le temps de se demander si
j'en suis au port et pourquoi ça je
compte le tuer avant
2 je les vois c'est bon
[Musique]
adil est ce que tu sais où hrf aucune
idée vous n'étiez pas ensemble non on
devait se rejoindre sur le site ça fait
un moment que tu l'as pas vu alors
demandé aux autres qui mange un peu plus
loin
d'accord mais merci bon appétit
aussi l'hymne tu vas bien tu veux nous a
manqué viens on va te faire une place
c'est gentil et août mais je voudrais
voir ses rêves mais pino tu l'avais ou
pas si on lui a parlé hier soir
apparemment il allait partir en mission
merci à plus tard aussi ne voulais pas
rester non et puis ça n'avait pas l'air
d'aller fort enfin j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
j'irai
c'est toi
je rêve
g rev
[Musique]
vous devez vous reposer pour guérir plus
rapidement
s'il vous plaît infirmières j'aimerais
finir de le lire je sais que bientôt il
va nous quitter je voudrais finir à sa
place s'il vous plaît infirmières
[Musique]
une
ouais
il est toujours là
alors tes copains ont laissé tout seul à
pourrir au soleil
[Musique]
le toit laisse toi tu veux mourir en
quoi acheter du tibet ces crétins
[Musique]
bon
un blessé
elle est saine
le monde
jean apporter une subsidiation invite
mara tenez bon
accrochez-vous muhsin allait emmener le
allez faites attention
sale bête
les turcs ont dû les entraîner nous
envoient leurs mouches et leur pouls
pour nous perturber
on devait être à mézos en seulement 3
jours et on est toujours là il nous
aurons à l'usure tu vas voir et oublier
les soldats gd pouplin la tête moi c'est
bon si j'avais des médocs qui nous en
aurait filé tu vois les officiers se
gratter la tête comme nous des mois des
médocs qu'ils en ont
ouvre les yeux de tony
est-ce que la morphine est arrivé les
anglais ont touché le bateau de
ravitaillement qui arrivait il va
falloir à tous impossible si on attend
il va mourir
les autres tentent de secours en manque
aussi noter qu'un pic
je vais le père et sans la
ce ne sera pas une patte plaisir pour
lui tout va bien se passer
2les une deuxième dose de morphine
quand pourra-t-il y retourner ça prendra
du temps monsieur il doit rentrer à
londres
c'est moi qui décide de qui rentre dites
moi combien de temps mettra sa blessure
à guérir et bien même si elle guérit il
sera inutile
l'homme que vous jugé inutile vaut
autant qu'un bataillon au complet alors
écoutez moi je vous donne une semaine
pour leur envoyer au combat sur le front
et fils ans ou celui qui le remplacera
ce sera vous et c'est vous qui reste sur
le terrain
à vous de choisir
[Musique]
vous aussi
réveille toi
amélie
kubel toualy
[Musique]
tu disais que tu tomberas jamais tu
devais pas m'abandonner qu'avait promis
réveille toi s'il te plaît
regardez comme il est pâle mademoiselle
dites-moi qui s'en sortira il a beaucoup
marché malgré sa blessure
le docteur pense que ça plaît plus
profonde parce que la balle a été fendu
ce qui aggrave toutes les blessures
oui mais s'en sortir il risque a payé
puisqu'il a eu la force de marché
jusqu'ici gardé espoir
horrible mais dites moi qu'il va se
réveiller qu'il va se réveiller au ciel
ou s'il doit vivre
il faut qu'ils seraient pas
[Musique]
e
c'était pas
vous voulez que j'assiste un sniper
c'est bien sûr monsieur précisément
beaucoup de soldats fera l affaire
pourquoi voulez-vous à sous-officier
pourquoi moi parce qu'aucun autre soldat
ou sous-officier que je connais dans ce
camp on a une mère allemande
je crois savoir que vous êtes né à
berlin
c'est bien exact oui monsieur mais enfin
quelle importance est important parce
que ça affecte la confiance que je place
en vous
le sniper dont je suis en train de vous
parler est dans la tente de secours
pendant qu'il récupère avant de
retourner se battre vous lui apporterez
tout ce qu ils tous qui le demandera
vous serez son assistant en quelques
sortes auger oublié de vous dire une
chose son partenaire a pris le bal en
plein coeur donc si vous voulez pouvoir
continuer à écrire en allemagne le temps
mais pas
[Musique]
lucide
tu vas bien
[Musique]
quand on rend visite à un malade on
apporte pas de la layette tu sais mais
des fleurs en général je voulais juste
montrer
[Musique]
j'avais peur que tu te réveilles pas
donc c'était pas facile pour moi
[Musique]
je suis soulagé je sais c'est pas trop
le moment mais
[Musique]
alors dit moi ça
fille ou garçon c'est un garçon gentil
ce futur champion
[Musique]
vous êtes donc maintenant un vétéran et
un oncle caporal motion son oncle
veillera sur lui toute sa vie il va
grandir avec les meilleurs parents qui
soient et aussi avec le meilleur oncle
qu'on puisse avoir
[Musique]
haas a dit moi une chose
es tu prêt à élever un enfant et à
l'aider à grandir
tortue sera là pour m'aider tout se
passera bien écoute moi petit frère
assad tu sais que si je dois mourir à la
guerre c'est toi qui deviendra le chef
de famille ne prend pas de mer en tout
cas pour l'instant 6 twh soldats insane
le pays est en guerre on ne sait pas ce
qui peut arriver
je suis déjà c'est mal en point n'oublie
jamais tous que je t'ai dit mon frère
c'est compris oui ces produits
il a déjà deux grands piétons petit il
ya fait un jerry deviendra grand celui
là comme son oncle j'espère
[Musique]
bonjour soldats bonjour je m'appelle
roche on fera équipe à présent on m'a
parlé de vous vous êtes tellement je ne
suis pas allemand je suis aussi anglais
que vous d'accord et je suis votre
supérieur hiérarchique
alors un peu de respect égal tenez
manger ça devrait accélérer votre
guérison et comment je louvre
la soupe froide j'ai fini par me faire
mais les mouches pas encore vous savez
il suffit simplement de verser de la
soupe par terre alors les mousses iront
par terre et plus dans votre assiette
non je préfère éviter le gaspillage on
manque déjà de tout ici à la fête ça
fonctionnera c'est mieux 4 ap la malaria
et après tout aussi hommage c'est pour
rester en vie non alors dans ce cas les
mouches montgeron ma ration je vous fais
confiance aussi laissez-moi vous aider
un peu vous avez l'air d'avoir du mal à
cause de votre maison ce n'est pas la
peine sauveur c'est mon travail il n'y a
pas de problème si je suis infirmière
c'est pour aider
[Musique]
e
comment va votre frère hassan et va
mieux capitaine un peu mieux de jour en
jour a coupé le lever surtout pas la
tête à couvert aucun shsh vous allez à
l'aller la tête baissée
un seul coup j'ai pas de vous êtes resté
bien caché derrière la voiture
oui mon capitaine
elio comment va costas ça va aller pour
capitaine y perd beaucoup de sang je
sais pas quoi faire il faut l'évacuer
est ce que quelqu'un voit le tireur non
j'ai pas eu à septembre rhdp rester à
couvert
bon je vais me forcer à tirer
[Musique]
regardez d'où le tir bien capitaine
trouver tout ça vient et tirer
[Musique]
quand le vent regarde de quel côté les
feuilles se penche comme hocine me le
répétait
tu dois cacher ton souffle dans l'air
respire le moins fort possible
leurs attentes
c'est bien beau gars sont un bon tir
mais je n'ai pas encore tiré moi c'était
pas beau ça alors qui a tiré
[Musique]
certaines prestations sa partie
accroche toi
ça va aller
[Musique]
cosmos
costaud
[Musique]
avec toi
coast to europe ace en matinée
m
obélix en main
à
toulouse joue peut être sympa et
et
[Musique]
est ce que tu me donnes
en couverture
une belle soirée
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une chose
ça
[Musique]
ban gamme l'école madame ou monsieur
aulas
gaudet du mektoub ingall 6 bat tarbes
le jour où tout le monde nous attend
lorsqu'obama signal
[Musique]
le colonel mustapha kemal vous en voyez
ceux ci s'est classé top secret bien
à l'attention exclusive du commandant
ahmed salim grâce à nos nombreuses
missions de renseignement nous sommes
parvenus à la conclusion évidente que
l'ennemi se prépare à une offensive
d'une grande ampleur dans ce but les
anglais ont déjà massées tout un arsenal
dans la bête dont ils ont dernièrement
pris le contrôle afin de contrer cette
attaque est de mener à bien nos futurs
sauf en civ
il est impératif que notre armée
détruisent la totalité de cet arsenal
dans le cas contraire il nous serait
impossible de résister à leurs assauts
étant donné nos faibles réserves tom et
de munitions je vous donne donc l'ordre
d'envoyer une équipe en infiltration
dans la paix pour détruire l'arsenal et
demi je suis certain que vous serez
choisir parmi nos valeureux soldats et
trouver les hommes les plus aptes à
participer à cette périlleuse mission
des hommes forts et courageux qui
n'hésiteront pas une seconde à sacrifier
leur propre vie pour le salut de notre
nation toute entière
je vous fais entièrement confiance pour
mener à bien cette opération décisive
mustafa kemal
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent faire avec tous
ces fusées t'es pas au courant l'état
major veut frapper un gros coup
il était temps je trouve
pardon je cherche à la salle oui c'est
moi hassan ya un problème n'ont rien de
grave le capitaine ibrahima deal veux
vous voir il m'a demandé de vous amener
au centre de commandement d'accord
j'arrive je vous attends dans la voiture
oui bon il est temps de se dire au
revoir
on ne reverra pas de sitôt je crois
pourquoi tu as été démobilisés non pas
du tout mais il va sûrement envoyé en
mission hassan un bon sniper comme toi
ça ne doit pas rester ici apporter des
caisses alors bonne chance mon ami bonne
chance à toi aussi
je suis contente de voir que vous
utilisez votre main je suis épuisée rien
que tu ailles et ce alors vous savez c g
eu après non soyez patient ce n'est pas
si simple
qu'est ce que vous faites je veux que
vous gardiez quelque chose de moi c'est
pour moi montre et je n'ai pas terminé
vous l'aurez plus tard bien
chez moi je faisais souvent des jolis
jouets en bois pour ali mais il est trop
grand maintenant il ne joue plus avec
hasan avait déjà un premier fils non non
ali et mon fils hassan est devenu père
pour la première fois le bébé n'a pas
encore de prénom
on choisira tous ensemble
[Musique]
auriez-vous perdu samoussy je les
trouvais dans la tente de secours après
votre arrivée
oui je croyais l'avoir perdue en vrai
c'est vraiment gentil
vraiment merci
[Musique]
et je m'en vais alors je dois aller
soigner des soldats blessés dans la
tente de secours si vous avez besoin le
docteur est à côté
non
bassil minutes
[Musique]
à mesbah avait demandé qu'on donne
toutes ses affaires aux pauvres de notre
village après son dessin
c'est la seule chose qui me reste d'elle
j'y tiens énormément
merci beaucoup
merci à vous aussi
[Musique]
ne faudra pas laisser le lit de cette
rivière sans surveillance
il y a une autre colline qui surplombe
l'arsenal jettent ici il faudra six
places et j'imagine qu'ils ont installé
des mitrailleuses ici pour protéger la
base au bord de la rivière
monsieur vous m'avez fait demander oui
merci essonne commandant le sniper dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
n'avancez êtes vous aussi bon sniper que
votre frère non loin de la commanderie
je sais tirer au fusil mais moins bien
que mon frère évidemment je ne suis pas
étonné muhsin est un tireur d'une
excellence rares s'attendre à un tel
niveau semaine absurde
lequel vous prenez celui de droite
vous en dites quoi nord sniper a dû se
vanter de m'avoir tués il aura une
surprise
pas mal quand il tourne mon bras n'est
plus même cet anglais avaient trafiqué
la balle apparamment tu t'en remettra
j'en suis sûr et certain
j'espère que tu as raison en tout cas
qu'est ce qui se passe à ça pourquoi tu
as l'air si inquiet sur moi que tu vas
pas t'énerver la dernière fois que tu
m'as dit ça tu avaient escaladé un muret
tu t'es tu es blessé tu t'en souviens
j'ai réussi à tuer un tireur isolé il y
a deux choix ah oui et le commandant
veut que j'y retourne je dois repartir
ambitions bien joué t'es pas fâché
pourquoi pourquoi ça m'énerve vrai que
mon frère est tuer un ennemi si le
commandant a choisi tu le mérites petit
frère alors bonne chance pour ce soir
merci j'en ai besoin
tiens parce que je vais oublier ça vient
d'arriver
parce que ça vient du village peut-être
j'en sais rien mais l'écriture est
différente de la dernière on dirait bien
qu alice et écrire il nous avait dit
qu'il aurait appris à notre retour s'est
fait apparemment à mon fils est
intelligent de l'abbaye ce pour qu'elle
totalise lui que tu viens me raconter
virale et qu'est ce que tu attends à san
van mission adil vous avez repéré les
lieux
oui aucune mauvaise surprise
leurs camps installés à côté de la
rivière sera parfait pour l'infiltration
ou commandant excellent à l'attack aura
lieu demain avant le lever du jour il y
a bel et bien une mitrailleuse placé sur
la colline pour surveiller tout
l'arsenal
les hommes devront donc s'en occuper
avant d'attaquer
alors je vous souhaite bonne chance
merci monsieur comme la mousse il m'a
bien guéri ses forces sont revenus vous
voulez que je vais parler de te son bras
est très endommagée la blessure a
affecté ses compétences on va le
renvoyer chez lui
[Musique]
adil
cette mission est très risqué
si l'un d'entre vous tombent au combat
pendant la mission alors tous les autres
soldats mourrons aussi vous le savez il
n'y a rien qu'on puisse faire avec un
soldat invalides pas en temps de guerre
son frère jouera son rôle à vos ordres
commandant
[Musique]
allez dire aux hommes de se préparer
c'est l'heure d'y aller
certains ne pourront pas venir monsieur
enver a été touché dans la tranchée
balles ennemies a transpercé sa main ne
peut plus tenir son fusil
[Musique]
on ira sans lui
malgré nos blessés et le manque de
ravitaillement je sais que l'autre
nation ne capitulera jamais
deux hommes auront toujours à coeur de
vaincre l'envahisseur
[Musique]
bonjour affermir weïss vous allez bien
bonjour hassan votre frère est installé
dans notre tante
merci oui je le sais j'étais avec lui
mais je viens de recevoir une lettre
mais si vous êtes occupé je repasserai
voyons comment se porte votre famille
alors c'est gentil qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est mauvais ah çà et là je te
cherche depuis un moment on part dans
cinq minutes je vais lire une lettre à
vis tu peux attendre cette plaie attend
un peu et lyon on est tous prêts on part
tout de suite tout est planifié il faut
se dépêcher
elle est bien tu écouteras ça plus tard
c'est rien de grave j'espère non vous
avez eu l'air triste en la lisant donc
ça m'a pas qu'aider le bpa était un peu
malade pendant quelques jours mais il va
beaucoup mieux je vous lirai tout à
votre retour de mission
oui et bien dans ce cas je vous la
laisse je compte bien revenir et vous me
lirez j'aimerai vous voir
faites attention à vous
vous êtes prêt muhsin oui mais je suis
déjà en retard tout le monde doit
m'attendre mohcine le docteur a parlé
aux commandes à vous rentrez chez vous
deux voies tropez qu'est ce que j'ai
fait
que je devrais rentrer chez moi
elle la blessure
elle est trop grave vous ne pouvez pas
rester je n'ai pas une balle qui aura
raison noah ne vous inquiétez pas et
puisque hassan a été pris pour cette
mission il n'ira pas sans moi il faut
que je protège mon frère dit à votre
docteur que je suis prêt à affronter les
anglais et que je quelqu'un à protéger
aussi il y à une autre personne que vous
devez protéger maintenant plus que tout
[Musique]
hassan a reçu un message aujourd'hui
votre fils
[Musique]
il a écrit que la femme d'hassan était
morte
[Musique]
hassan est dans la benne me alors je ne
lui ai pas dit pour ne pas le perturber
[Musique]
où est il allé vous dit adil les emmène
en mission d'infiltration dans la paix
près de la rivière
houcine ce serait un miracle qu'il
puisse revenir vivant et vous le savez
mieux que moi c'est quelque chose arrivé
à san ce serait alors à vous de les
lever ne pourrait pas vers la mort que
penserait mon fils il apprenait que j'ai
abandonné son oncle combat et comment
sera mon neveu quand il aura grandi
je ne peux quand même pas abandonner mon
frère soit je le ramènerait chez nous en
un seul morceau soit je mourrais à ses
côtés sur le champ de bataille
essayez pas de mon empêcher bay ce jeu
ne peut pas l'abandonner
je n'entre pas sans lui il a besoin de
moi souhaitez-moi versant s'ils ne
partent pas ou s'il n'y allez pas vous
ne reviendrait jamais
je partais pas
pourquoi vivre n'en vaut pas la peine si
on n'est pas prêt à se sacrifier par
amour
et puis les soldats peuvent mourir à
tout moment
l'avenir est une chose à laquelle on ne
pense pas je le regretterai toute ma vie
si je reste si je ne vais pas été à ça
je sais que je ne pourrai jamais me le
pardonner
[Musique]
au revoir piste
je laissais votre cadeau sur l'oreiller
j'espère rentrer pour vous voir avec
si je ne rentre pas alors
souvenez vous de moi quand vous le
porterez
[Musique]
se souvenir c'est pour les gens qui
oublient
[Musique]
moi je ne vous oublierai jamais
muhsin qu'est ce que tu fais ici
on m'a dit que vous aviez est envoyé en
infiltration ici je suis venu te rendre
une petite visite
fallait pas ça me fait plaisir
bah ça
oui mon frère tu as jeunes pas mourir
s'il te plaît ne meurt pas
comment je pourrais impossible mon frère
me protège
allez ce rêve c'est quand
[Musique]
aller chercher l'émission rapporte que
tout brûle
j'avais quelqu'un tue celui de planquer
sur la colline
[Musique]
bon sang mais google
il
[Musique]
je
mais
[Musique]
d'abord allés piller les mois
sortez les munitions
[Musique]
il faut pas rester là à yomou meilleurs
lots région
[Musique]
on retrouvera vite et j'arrive à la
maison
d'énergie pour couvrir - muhsin ne
pourra salle lâche moi quoi tu sais moi
qui vais y aller
d'accord du moins pas avant d'avoir
entendu la voix de son fils
rester si t'es pas rentrer pour voir son
fils ali a grandi sans sa mère
suis sûr qu'il sera vivre sans son père
décembre risque pas ton caporal dordonne
de partir c'est compris tu vas rester
pour me couvrir pendant que je
descendrai vers l'arsenal et à mon
signal court le plus vite possible
d'accord non moi je venais d'acheter ça
sonne ton fils devra grandir sur sa mère
comme ali elle est morte
mais son père est encore en vie
[Musique]
je suis vraiment étonné salle
on va s'occuper de tourisme d'hiver
[Musique]
tant mieux si bien
mossi
baj
les cheveux il boîtant ne veut grandir
ça
cousine qu'avant
palais à sanaa dès maintenant olé
ah oui
d
m
passage
c'est vrai
septembre est ravi
il ne comprend pas ton corps mon frère
ça nous arrive
[Musique]
cessez le feu ne dirai plus top
laissez le moi
laissez moi ce plaisir
vous êtes arrivé à gallipoli
vous n'irez pas plus haut rhin
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il